[Musik]
wer noch gibt es ja beispielsweise im
öffentlichen rundfunk jetzt eine satire
über die alten darin hieß es in einem
tv-spot corona auf die alten dahin
das ist nur gerecht denn die generation
65 plus habe den planeten vor die wand
gefahren
zitat ende empfinden sie sowas
eigentlich lustig ist das satire das ist
einfach nur widerlich
nein ich halte das für dazu kanäle und
zwar deshalb das ist die sprache der
gosse wie ich nicht haben möchte
das ist die sprache derjenigen die mit
grobheiten zu tun haben die spalten
wollen die letzten endes ihr eigenes
vergnügen daran haben etwas auseinander
zu bringen
das ist etwas was ich nicht billige und
was ich fürchterlich finde und was sich
deshalb auch für dann finde dass ich als
quasi steuerzahler letzten ist noch über
mein gebühren ein solchen und wo solche
niedertracht finanziert muss das uns
ganz klipp und klar sein wie zahle ich
noch eins ich stamme aus einer familie
wo mein vater aus einem stapel gefängnis
kam und er kam nach hause
wir haben ihn nicht gefragt wie es ihm
ging sondern ich habe erlebt dass jetzt
wieder die rechte von solchen unkenrufen
wieder gemacht werden von leuten nieder
haupt und die man satire nennen die
fertigen nation gespalten werden das
halte ich gefühlt ich bin der meinung
dass gerade die situation wie wir sie
jetzt haben eine notsituation und an
situation dass jung und alt zusammen
hält um den generationen aus wald und
zusammenhalten
dieses problem gelöst wird das ist die
frage und ich find es fürchterlich dass
in der öffentlichkeit über und fern sind
solche meldung verbreitet werden das bin
ich schlimm dass die lässig das sind
grob dass eine verheerende situation
erwarten sie eine entschuldigung von den
verantwortlichen
ich glaube dass die sich nun platz
entschuldigung können naja die
verantwortlichen öffentlich rechtlichen
die können sie natürlich entschuldigen
dem harz
der meinung dass die verantwortlichen
hier mal wird es ein deutliches wort
sprechen müssen dass so etwas wird
gesendet werden da haben sie aktuell
angst um ihre gesundheit empfangen sie
noch gerne besuch von ihrer familie
beispielsweise natürlich empfangene
immer sehr gerne besucht insbesondere
auch von meinen enkelkindern nur auf der
anderen seite merkte ich aber auch dass
menschen in meinem alter eine ganz
anderes gefühl entwickelt haben und auch
eine distanz entwickelt haben zugefahren
ich habe gestern noch mit meinen kindern
darüber gesprochen und ihnen mal gesagt
wie wir am morgen gefühlt haben wenn
bombenangriffe vorbei waren und wenn wir
wussten ankommenden ankommen die
nächsten
wir haben uns mitgefahren und abfinden
müssen und wir haben auch mit den
gefahren leben müssen
wir müssen auch persönlich gefühlsmäßig
eine distanz zu entwickeln um nicht in
panik zu geraten oder hier glaube ich
ist die erfahrung der eltern gegenüber
den juden jetzt gefordert wo wir auch
zumindest den bürgern sagen dass man
letzten endes die gefahren ich noch
angst man kann sondern auch mit ganz
konkreter konzentration auf die die wir
haben um sie zur wäre angesprochen auch
von religion und jungen was in
übereinstimmung ist auch mit der
senioren-union dass wir uns gemeinsam
bemühen wollen jetzt speziell auch bei
älteren menschen zu helfen oder eben zu
mainz beim einkaufen zu helfen nicht nur
die jüngeren sondern auch die eltern die
damit machen die sich noch dazu fähig
fühlen und sich auch verantworten fühlen
und ich glaube dass diese epidemie die
dieses land befallen hat eine grosse
chance bietet für die gemeinsamkeit für
jung und alt die zusammenstehen und
dieses problem auch gemeinsam lösen
wollen
dazu haben wir uns auch entschlossen und
ich glaube dass das auch manchen open
rufen so wieder so klappen wird
wir sehen eine chance wir müssen sie
wahrnehmen auch im interesse der
ski-nation konflikte verhindert wird
[Musik]